since russia's invasion of ukraine on
february 24th countries around the world
have responded with sweeping sanctions
nato countries fearing that any kind of
military engagement in the conflict
could trigger a fully fledged war with
the rest of europe and its allies have
opted for an economic offensive instead
countries around the world have frozen
russian assets they've barred the
majority of russian banks from the swift
international payment system and they've
sanctioned russian oligarchs and more
new restrictions intended to [ __ ] the
russian economy are being announced on a
near daily basis and the rupal's value
has plummeted with economic forecasters
predicting the russian economy will
shrink by 7 to 15 this year
but will the aggressive sanctions be
enough to stop russia's war in ukraine
and what impact are they likely to have
in russia and across the world joining
me to discuss this is sergey goryev
economist and scientific director of the
master and phd programs in economics as
seance po paris thank you so much for
joining me on upfront
russian president vladimir putin has
called the western sanctions on russia
akin to a declaration of war meanwhile
the u.s and the eu are escalating
sanctions including a ban from the u.s
this week on russian oil and natural gas
imports and yet as civilian casualties
in ukraine continue to rise many are
saying that the sanctions
actually aren't even enough where do you
stand on that
i do think that uh sanctions are not
enough in a sense that behavior has not
changed vladimir putin is doubling down
on the war and initially the sanctions
were a deterrent than an instrument to
change behavior
and now the situation is changing in a
sense that putin says i will not stop i
will bomb ukrainian cities i will try to
capture kiev and change the government
in ukraine even though occasionally he
says no it's not my goal
um but
but overall
overall right now sanctions are to uh
increase cost for russian economy for mr
putin and make sure he doesn't have
enough financial resources to continue
the war now mr putin has two fronts
he has unhappy russians at home who are
hit by the sanctions
who would like to protest against the
war because the war is actually quite
unpopular it is not a provoked war it's
a as president biden would say war of
choice
um and the front in ukraine so he needs
a lot of money to pay his policemen in
russia to beat up protesters to pay his
propagandies to convince whoever can be
convinced that this is a just war
and defensive war and then of course to
pay his soldiers in ukraine and in order
to make sure that he doesn't have enough
money indeed u.s has now hit
the most important source of currency
and budget revenues which is oil experts
and u.s is not a big importer of russian
oil but u.s has been joined by the
private sector this is very important to
understand private companies like shell
or bp or myersk
do not have to
stop buying russian oil and transporting
russian oil but they do they they have
actually self-imposed the sanctions on
russian oil which is now becoming toxic
for reputational reasons and in that
sense right now russian oil exports are
disrupted and therefore russia is being
deprived of those resources but there is
now a debate that europe should join
american embargo and that would really
hit uh vladimir putin hard because
europe is the main market for russian
oil and gas the ruble is now worth less
than one u.s penny we've seen long lines
of russians waiting for atm machines
we've seen predictions that russian
inflation will hit up to 17 this year
and people are stocking up on medicines
about 55 percent of which are imported
uh do you believe that the hardships
that are being imposed on ordinary
russians as a result of the sanctions
will be effective uh if anything in
fueling dissent against putin or
is his hold on power
uh so strong that it won't matter
so regimes like this change behavior or
get replaced through two sources a
palace coup by the elite or indeed by
mass protests when the policemen
don't want to shoot
and so mr putin is afraid of both
elites are very unhappy imagine you've
been building a company for 20 or 30
years and it's destroyed in one week
which for example has happened to many
russian businesses now with the
population as you rightly said
population is unhappy as well
but then again mr putin is smart here he
plays divide and rule with the elite and
threatens uh jaylen and poisoning them
but also he invests a lot in
brainwashing the population saying
you're suffering but this is economic
aggression by the west and we are
innocent we are a victim
or he also invests in uh riot police and
so you're unhappy about the fact that
your deposits are frozen and you cannot
afford the medicines and i think that
you point pinpointed the very very very
important issue because for many
russians the main two expanded consumer
expenditures are food and medicines and
medicines are important and whichever
are not imported are also priced to
reflect their global price of medicine
and so in that sense real russians are
now going below the poverty line but can
they protest against that the answer is
no because the putin's police is still
well paid and happy to beat up the
protesters and so unless mr putin is
deprived of fiscal revenue which is
petra dollars in the end of the day
he will double down another piece of
this is the impact of economic sanctions
not just on russia but on the broader
global arrangement of power and global
economic circumstance uh the wall street
journal recently predicted that
sanctions will have quote the biggest
impact on the global economy of any such
moves since
1945 because of the sheer size of course
of the russian economy we're already
seeing fuel prices rise uh in the eu and
in the united states the question though
for many including myself is
is the price of sanctions worth the cost
that they'll have for the rest of the
world
well as they say in russia remember
those happy pandemic times right so this
is much bigger than koveta
this is uh in europe people think about
this as 1939. and indeed already now we
have more than two million refugees from
ukraine that's bigger than the refugee
crisis of 2015 2016. and the expected
number as of today is 5 million this is
the biggest refugee crisis in
europe since 1945 and on top of that mr
putin has nuclear weapons and so in that
sense in that sense it's really a
historic moment
which is somewhat similar in 1939 and so
a lot of countries say whatever the
price of sanctions we need to stop this
aggressor because this aggressor is not
going to be appeased and this indeed
this is true because uh putin invaded
ukraine in 2014
and people thought well he's got what he
wanted that's fine he'll go back and
he'll never
uh invade us again but what has happened
the problem is if your app is an
aggressor like in 1938 you may get
another aggression and yet another
aggression and that's why the west tries
to fight this battle now you're right
that people talk too much about uh the
pain of higher oil and gas prices for
europe but it's going to be a much
bigger pain for developing countries
which don't have such big coffers and
access to that uh markets and on top of
the oil there is also grain because both
russia and ukraine are biggest exporters
of grain and those exports will be
disrupted for sure so things like uh
things like
oil prices grain prices some other
things and of course this massive
refugee flows these are not uh not
outcomes we would love to see
but the alternative is that there'll be
more crisis like this because as i said
mr putin has shown
he doesn't like peace he prefers war to
cooperation trade and investment do you
believe that the international community
is able to offer moscow an exit strategy
from the crisis and if so
what does it look like
so um
there'll be negotiation at some point
when mr putin runs out of resources
and cannot
continue his offensive anymore there
will be some kind of negotiation and
indeed mr putin will probably want to
come back to russian voters and say we
won
and so this is this is a big question
how to define this victory ukraine will
never recognize annexation of crimea or
independence of donetsk and lugansk if
mr putin grabs more land ukraine will
not recognize
that this land is not ukrainian anymore
but what may happen is a frozen conflict
a de facto occupation of part of
ukrainian territory and depending on
ukrainian resistance
which is of course beyond belief it's
really really brave
um
uh
this grab of land may be big or small we
don't know how much mr putin will be
able to progress how much resistance he
will see maybe he will be pushed back to
pre-war uh line of separation life of
line of conflict but this is um
this is something which is very hard to
predict another thing which is happening
is outside of russia russians actually
say this is not our war and we will want
um to tell the whole world that mr putin
doesn't represent russia and that is
also something that will help to push mr
putin back as well
uh we for example establish the
uh
fundraising initiative simply called
through russia the true russia where we
we russians abroad fundraise for
ukrainian refugees to show that we don't
share what mr putin does uh we
don't believe that he killing uh
ukrainians in our name
is is is something we should be blamed
for so we don't uh remain silent and we
will help ukrainians who suffer from mr
putin and i hope that ukrainians will be
able to defend their country
okay grieve thank you so much for
joining me on upfront
thank you thank you mark that is our
show up front we'll be back
you